Dr Zakia could you tell us the
prerequisites for uh iaf and is indeed
uh one of the prerequisites
fasting as far as the prerequisites for
doing e is concerned but the person
should be Muslim he should be
sane he should have reached puberty and
he should not be in the state of janaba
ceremonial impurity he should not be
sexually
defiled person should not be in the
state of menstration or post child birth
bleeding and the person should be pure
while doing and besides these there are
two pillars of EA number one that is the
intention his Nia should be seeking
nearness to Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
seeking his reward number two is it
should be done in a mosque as Allah says
in Sur Bak chapter number two verse
number 187 that associate not with your
wives when you retreat in the mosque
Supernatural while doing you should not
associate with your wife don't have a
sexual relationship they discussed in
the last answer and number two it should
be done in a
mosque and people
differ some of the people say it can be
any mosque but the majority of the
scholars say that it should not be any
mosque it should be a Mosk in which
congregation Salah are
offered and it should also be in a
mosque in which jum Salah is offered
because if congregation Salah is not
offered and if a person is doing a in
the mosque it either mean that he's not
offering San congregation which is not
correct or he may be going out to
another mosque that defeats the B
of so but natural most of the scholars
agree that it should be in a mosque
which has regular congregation Salah and
preferably even Juma Salah should be
offered in that
mosque and they the prerequisite as is
mentioned in AB volume number two in the
book of fasting Hadith number
2467 that it Sunnah for a person that he
should not visit a patient or attend a
funeral or Embrace his wife asso his
wife and should not leave the mosque
except if there's a basic necess a basic
need as far as whether fasting is
compulsory or
not it's mention with in the same of
number two in the book of fasting number
2467 says that there's
no without fasting that's her view but
if you read say bukari Vol number eight
in the book of Oaths and vs Hadith
number
6697 which we quoted
earlier with him he said that in the
days of
ignorance before he accepted Islam he
had vowed that he will DOA for one night
in MJ Haram and the prophet said fulfill
your W and there's no fasting during
night so by this permission of the
Prophet it is understood that fasting is
not F but it is must it's a recommended
sunah that if you fast it's preferable
it's not a f to fast while doing